REMAIN YESTERDAY BUT NOW WILL
REMAIN UNTIL A SUCCESSOR IS
PICKED.
THE WAY FORWARD ON CAPITOL HILL
WITH THE IMPEACHMENT IS CLOUDY.
LEGAL FIGHTS WITH PARTISAN
SHOWDOWNS.
PLUS, PARTY LEADERS ARE WEIGHING
THE POLITICAL IMPLICATIONS HADE
AHEAD OF THE AHEAD OF THE 2020
ELECTION.
>> HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
SAID SHE EXPECTS PUBLIC HEARINGS
TO BEGIN THIS MONTH BUT TELLS
BLOOMBERG NEWS THERE IS NO
DEADLINE TO FINISH.
>> WE THINK THE TIMES HAVE FOUND
US.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE IS
TO SAY THE THREE SEPARATE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT, FORGET
THAT, ARTICLE TWO, IT'S ABOUT
ME, I CAN DO THAT.
>> HOUSE LEADERS HAVE NOT YET
RELEASED A CALENDAR FOR PUBLIC
HEARINGS AND AN EVENTUAL VOTE ON
RECOMMENDING ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
FOR NOW THE MAJORITY IS MUM.
>> I CAN'T ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
>> INTERNAL QUESTIONS OF A TIME
LINE CONTINUE TAKING SHAPE.
WHILE THE HOUSE IS IN RECESS
NEXT WEEK THERE WILL BE MORE
DEPOSITIONS INCLUDING WITH JOHN
BOLTON BUT HIS LAWYERS SAY HE
MAY NOT APPEAR.
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS NO
SUBPOENA HAS BEEN ISSUED OF YET.
SEVERAL WEEKS OF HEARINGS WOULD
FOLLOW AND COULD BE WRAPPED UP
SOMETIME IN DECEMBER.
AFTER INTELLIGENCE RELEASES ITS
INVESTIGATORY FINDINGS, IN
JUDICIARY LAWYERS FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP WOULD ALSO BE ALLOWED TO
QUESTION WITNESSES AND PRESENT
ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE.
IF IT GOES TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THE CHAIRMAN HAS FULL
DISCRETION TO DENY WITNESSES.
VETO POWER BY THE CHAIRMAN.
>> AFTER
>> IF PASSED THE MATTER GOES TO
THE SENATE FOR A TRIAL WHICH
COULD BE HELD AS EARLY AS
JANUARY.
OVERLY OPTIMISTIC IN THE EYES OF
MANY ON THE HILL.
>> I HOPE THAT THE PRESIDENCY
HAS NOT BEEN HARMED.
>> BILL CLINTON'S 1998 TRIAL
LASTED FIVE WEEKS.
THAT PUTS ANY TRUMP TRIAL ENDING
AROUND THE FIRST 2020 CAUCUSES
AND PRIMARIES IN FEBRUARY.
THE WILD CARD IS A PROTRACTED
COURT FIGHT WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
AND INDIVIDUAL WITNESSES
CHALLENGING HOUSE SUBPOENAS AND
DEMOCRATS FEAR ANY DELAY TACTICS
BY REPUBLICANS COULD DRAG THE
PROCESS ON INDEFINITELY.
ANOTHER COMPLICATION.
PELOSI HINTED THE HOUSE PROBE
COULD GO BEYOND THE PRESIDENT'S